THIS HURRICANE PROBABLY HAVE
BEEN A CAT 2.
KARL ROVE IS A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, AND NO STRANGER TO
THESE TYPES OF THEATRICS.
YOU MUST HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS
DURING KATRINA PROBABLY.
>> NOT AS BAD AS THIS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
INTERESTED ME, LOOK, UNDER THE
LAWS THAT GOVERN THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS, FEMA, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RELATES TO THE
GOVERNOR.
THE GOVERNOR RELATES TO ALL THE
LOCALS.
BEFORE THIS EVENT OCCURRED,
PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLED THE
MAYORS OF SEVERAL LARGEST CITIEO
FORTH -- DIRECTLY LONG BEFORE,
SEVERAL DAYS BEFORE, HE CALLED
GOVERNOR DESANTIS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
UNNECESSARY STAB AT THE
GOVERNOR.
THE GOVERNOR FORTUNATELY DID NOT
RISE TO THE BAIT.
HE WENT OUT AND WAS APPRECIATIVE
OF PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CALL.
COMPLIMENTED FEMA ON THE WORK
THEY WERE DOING IN PREPARATION
OF THE EVENT.
IT WAS A SIGN IN AN
INAPPROPRIATE WAY, PRESIDENT
BIDEN SHOULD HAVE BETTER SENSE
TO TALK TO THE GUY THAT I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE TALKING TO, THE
GOVERNOR, MAKING CERTAIN THAT HE
HAS ALL THAT HE NEEDS, BECAUSE
HE'S THE GUY THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE IN TOUCH WITH THE MAYORS AND
COUNTY LEADERS.
>> Jesse: DO YOU REMEMBER SANDY,
OBAMA HAD THE OFFICIAL JACKET,
AND GOT HUGGED BY CHRIS
CHRISTIE.
REPUBLICANS WERE FURIOUS.
IT'S COSTING US.
IS BIDEN GOING TO FLY TO
FLORIDA, TRY TO HUG RON
DESANTIS, AND SHOULD RON
DESANTIS HUG HIM BACK?
>> LOOK, IT'S APPROPRIATE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE LAW.
PEOPLE LIKE HAVING THE PRESIDENT
COME IN AN AFTERMATH OF
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
LOOK, WHAT I THINK GOVERNOR
DESANTIS IS KEEP THE POLITICS
OUT OF THIS.
HE'S COMPLETELY FOCUSED ON DOING
HIS JOB.
IF THE PRESIDENT COMES TO VISIT,
HE SHOULD WELCOME HIM, THANK HIM
FOR HIS ASSISTANCE.
I'M ABSOLUTELY CONFIDENT HE
WILL.
AND REMEMBER, IF YOU STEP BACK
FROM THIS, THE ONLY POLITICS
ABOUT THIS IS IF YOU'RE UP TO
THE JOB.
IF YOU'RE THE MAYOR OF NEW
ORLEANS, AND YOU DON'T SEEM TO
BE UP TO THE JOB AFTER KATRINA,
THE VOTERS RESPOND.
IF YOU'RE THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA, LIKE JEB BUSH, AND
THOSE BEFORE AND AFTER HIM,
GOVERNOR SCOTT WHO SEEMED TO BE
IN CHARGE OF THESE THINGS, DOING
THE RIGHT THING, THEY'RE
REWARDED BY THE PEOPLE OF THEIR
STATE, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANT A GOVERNOR TO DO, TO BE IN
CHARGE OF SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WHEN THE MOMENT COMES.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK IF RON
DESANTIS RENAMED FLORIDA UKRAINE
JOE BIDEN WOULD GIVE HIM THE
FEDERAL AID FASTER?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, HE DID --
GOVERNOR DESANTIS MADE THIS
POINT, THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- THE -- THE -- THE
STATE OF FLORIDA SENT ITS
INITIAL REQUEST, THEY
IMMEDIATELY RESPONDED AND SAID
YES.
THEY MADE A REQUEST FOR WHAT'S
CALLED INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE.
YOU HEARD THE GOVERNOR JUST
REFLECT ON IT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RESPONDED
AND SAID YES.
SO FAR WE HAVEN'T SEEN POLITICS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DELIVERY OF
THE AID.
LET'S HOPE NOT, THAT THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS THAT HAS TO
RELATE TO THE STATE KEEPS THE
POLITICS OUT OF IT.
THAT'S WHAT -- THAT'S WHAT IN
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS ALIKE THEY'VE
DONE IN THE PAST.
LET'S HOPE THEY CONTINUE TO DO
IT IN THE FUTURE.
>> Jesse: THIS CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE, THE HURRICANE.
THE REPUBLICANS WERE CLOSING THE
GAP, THEY GOT THE MOMENTUM BACK,
EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS NOT
DEMOCRAT MOMENTUM, THAT WAS FAKE
NEWS IN THE MEDIA, BUT
CANDIDATES ARE CLOSING STRONG ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
CRIME, IMMIGRATION, INFLATION,
STOCK MARKET'S TANKING.
THIS HURRICANE COMES, HOW DOES
THIS AFFECT THE LANDSCAPE?
INTEREST WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
IT FOR A FEW DAYS.
IT'S GOING TO OVERSHADOW THE
CAMPAIGNS IN, SAY, PENNSYLVANIA
AND NEVADA.
IT'S GOING TO EFFECT, FOR GOOD
OR FOR ILL, I SUSPECT FOR GOOD,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS IN FLORIDA,
GOVERNOR KEMP, AND McMASTER.
IF YOU'RE A GOVERNOR OF A STATE
THAT GETS HIT BY HURRICANES, YOU
THINK ABOUT THIS AND PLAN ABOUT
THIS, AND TRAIN FOR THIS A LOT.
I SUSPECT WE'LL SEE ALL THREE OF
THOSE GOVERNORS RISE TO THE
CHALLENGE.
>> Jesse: WHAT'S THE GLOBAL
WARMING GAME THEY'RE PLAYING?
>> YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT THAT WAS
INTERESTING.
THERE'S THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
NOAA, THE NATIONAL OCEANIC AND
ATMOSPHERIC ADMINISTRATION
AGENCY, WHO SAYS TO TOM LEMON,
I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO THAT.
IF DON IS RIGHT, THEY'RE
INTENSIFYING, HE HAS TO EXPLAIN
WHY WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THERE'S BEEN AS MANY AS 60,
70, ATE, 90 YEARS AGO, EVEN MORE
POWERFUL HURRICANES THAT HIT
FLORIDA.
LOOK, HE WAS RIGHT TO GET INTO
THIS.
YOU SAID YOU CAN'T TAKE GLOBAL
WARMING AND RELATE IT TO A
SPECIFIC EVENT.
DON LEMON WAS SO DESPERATE TO
SAY, THIS IS GLOBAL WARMING, AND
THEREFORE WE NEED TO PASS THE
BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN WITH
GREEN ENERGY PROVISIONS, AND AOC
OUGHT TO BE IN CARRIAGE OF THIS,
AND IF WE DO THAT WE'LL NEVER
HAVE A BAD ONE AGAIN.
THAT'S NOT HOW THE WEATHER
LIKES.
>> Jesse: AND HE SAYS HE USED TO
LIVE IN FLORIDA, AND HE KNOWS.
THAT'S BASICALLY SCIENCE.
YOU'RE A HISTORIAN.
THE SEMINOLE INDIANS HUNDREDS OF
YEARS AGO, HOW WERE THEY AT
DETECT THE HURRICANE SPEEDS AND
RAINFALL?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO THE EDGE
OF MY HISTORICAL, YOU KNOW,
INFORMATION.
I CANNOT RESPOND TO YOU ON THAT.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
BIG WIND, HEAVY WATER.
>> Jesse: WE'VE ONLY STARTED
MEASURING THE VORACITY OF
HURRICANES THE LAST 70-80 YEARS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT GLOBAL
WARMING HAS MADE THEM STRONGER.
WE ONLY JUST STARTED MEASURING
THEM.
>> LOOK, THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE.
THE HEAD OF NOAA WAS RIGHT,
LET'S STAY FOCUSED ON THE EVENT
AT HAND, AND SECOND OF ALL, NO
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN GLOBAL
WARMING AND SPECIFIC EVENTS.
>> Jesse: I'M GLAD THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF SOLAR PANELS IN
FLORIDA, BECAUSE T